crammed inside this art studio on the
outskirts of ghana's capital accra
daniel jasper is finishing up the final
touches on a work commissioned by a
foreign collector the veteran movie
poster designer is well known in ghana
for putting paintbrush to canvas over
the past 30 odd years inspired by some
of the world's most popular films
but the market for his work which once
had canadians clamoring for cinema seats
has changed
i mean bit interest more okay
people are no longer interested in going
out to watch a movie when it can be
watched from the comfort of their own
phone but there is a growing interest in
owning these hand-painted posters
internationally when someone watches a
movie and they like it they might place
an order for a poster and now they hang
them in private rooms or show them in
exhibitions
from the 1970s ghana developed a
tradition of advertising films with
these vibrant hand-painted posters
at the time local cinemas were
flourishing and artists competed over
who could entice the largest audience
with their imaginative eye-popping
designs but with the rise of the
internet the curtain came down on
ghana's independent cinemas
joseph frimpong is a university
professor in pop culture anthropology
we need to have a way of motivating
you know
upcoming artists to be rooted in this
tradition right of course they can you
know you know they can
you know move on to other art forms but
to preserve this way of painting we need
to have a way of you know motivating
these artists you know to grow
while jasper's work has gained
international appeal young artists
struggle to gain the same recognition
many turn to painting shop signs or
commissioned portraits to make a living
jasper says to keep the cinema poster
tradition alive up and coming artists
must be taught how to earn from their
work
international demand has given us the
money to sustain our careers so we teach
the younger generation so that they too
have something with which they can take
care of themselves
passing on the paintbrush for future
generations
jillian wolf al jazeera